Republican state senators in Oregon are
in hiding this morning trying to avoid a
vote on a controversial climate bill 11
GOP lawmakers walked off the job last
week Carter Evans reports on the growing
political standoff activists who want
the Oregon State Senate to pass a
controversial climate bill are running
out of time with only 5 days left in the
legislative session the Senate doesn't
have enough people to vote on the bill
or the more than 100 other bills
including funding for state agencies
that are at risk of being scrapped they
are turning their backs on Oregonians
and they are turning their backs on the
democratic process Republicans have
refused to show up for work since last
Thursday frustrating some voters why do
we elect them if they're not going to
make a decision for us
Governor Brown authorized state police
to track them down but many have fled to
neighboring states including state
senator Tim Kenobi
where are you the bill would put a hard
cap on greenhouse gas emissions and
increase a variety of taxes republicans
argue it would hurt jobs and raise gas
prices some Republicans are taking a
more extreme stance one told the
Portland TV station send bachelors
income heavily-armed I'm not going to be
a political prisoner in the state of
work that seemed to encourage local
militias and over the weekend
authorities warned Democrats of a
possible threat to the capital it is
absolutely outrageous in Oregon this is
not how we solve problems for CBS this
morning Carter Evans Salem Oregon
commensal chillin city bachelors
democracy can't work if you run out of
the room every time it gets hard I think
that's the way lawmakers should respond
to maybe they should pass the law
preventing this kind of thing never get
back together
yes exactly there's a better way